[Music]
well you were watching the film
especially when everything comes
together you know from the from the
music to the editing and all the effects
what was the point where you cried I did
kind of have my panic attacks is that
okay is that not the action that's fine
yeah it was actually when we were sat
yeah Lucasfilm at the ranch and we were
watching the film for the first time it
was on my birthday I should for the
first time on your birthday yeah I know
the present yeah it was awesome they are
requesting a callsign Rogue rogue one
and so the the music came up and it said
Star Wars on the screen and I just
thought I kind of like hearing that wow
what's that like loud drumming noise and
realized it's like my pulse in my ears
just kind of like yeah I just I a crazy
amount of adrenaline kind of shooting
through me right almost kind of just
take a few deep breaths cuz it was like
this is surreal this isn't it just
didn't feel real none of it felt real
really I was kind of looking over at the
other actors you like you seen this -
they were just watching looking ahead
shut up watching the thing I had that
same reaction but yeah this is real wise
razor - Phil no was Phil that was stupid
oh really I just thought what I was
watching and I was like there isn't a
new Star Wars movie coming out right now
I'm not watching this and I had a
blacked out and I'd watch it a second
time and I was like this is happening Oh
sir
I mean Brooklyn has the most badass
Vader scene of the entire franchise I
know we didn't they kept that from us
that was never in the script we didn't
know about it was the first time we saw
it was that our cases films finish like
Darth Vader
epilogue like what's going on here and
we just all started shouting and
cheering and clapping you know in a
screening room yeah that was a sneaky
one that was very sneaky had no idea no
I didn't know about that
[Music]
you